hey I'm Haley  hello down the road Amelia you say  you're what like allergic to the world  right I guess you could say that they  looked everywhere for doctor it helps  you usually get better promise  hello Eli I'm dr. horn well I hope you  don't think of this as a medical  facility to me it's a home and for now  it's your home so everything we hoped  for is right here shall we begin  what do you think is making you sick  lots of things fear water dust Eli's  gonna get worse before he gets better  gosh something in my room  bad dreams are a side effect it's  perfectly normal I don't need to freak  you out with this place gives me the  creeps  I think she's making me sicker medical  it's not the medication why do I feel  worse because it's working  I think something bad is happening  [Music]  [Music]  in danger  [Music]  you're gonna get better promise  you  you